[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
هل تعلم أنهم كانوا يقطعون المياه في
نطاق
لم يتم تقنينه ، ثم
يجب أن يكون متساويًا في جميع أنحاء المدينة ،
وجدنا صنابير مياه غير قانونية تعمل
في العراء ، نعم
هناك شخص ما يحميهم
[موسيقى  ]
معروف لدى الكثيرين بأن والدة
كراتشي قُتلت على يد مسلح ، وبالكاد
طرحت الشرطة أي أسئلة في مكان الحادث ولم يتم
التحقيق ، فماذا سيتبقى
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، شكرًا لك على
إعطائنا الوقت لهذه المقابلة ونتمنى
لك عيد ميلاد سعيد  وعطلات سعيدة
وأورلاندو ، كيف
تقدم نفسك عادة للجمهور ، أود أن
أقول إنني أورلاندو فان إمبي أم وأنا صانع
أفلام ، هل كنت دائمًا صانع أفلام ،
هل تعلم أن لدي طريقًا غريبًا جدًا
في صناعة الأفلام 2  كنت
متزلجًا محترفًا على الجليد منذ
فترة طويلة وتعلمت كيفية صنع الأفلام من
خلال
تعلم كيفية تصوير أصدقائي وهم
يتزلجون على الجليد والتقاط صور
لهم وهذا النوع من جعلني
في صناعة الأفلام ثم  في الواقع ، لقد انحرفت
نوعًا ما
في صناعة الأفلام الوثائقية
، وقد وضعني هذا النوع على مسار
صنع أفلامًا وثائقية في الغالب
، ويبدو أنك مهتم دائمًا
بالأسباب الاجتماعية أو الجغرافيا السياسية ،
لماذا يوجد هذا النوع من
الاهتمام ، وأين يأتي.  من
صناعة الأفلام هي عملية بطيئة للغاية
تتطلب منك معرفة بعض الأفلام التي يمكنك قضاء
سنوات في العمل عليها 2 على الأقل بالنسبة
لي يجب أن أؤمن حقًا
بالموضوع الذي يجب أن أهتم به.
استثمرت في الأشخاص
الذين يدور حولهم الفيلم إذا كنت
سأكرس جزءًا كبيرًا من
حياتي لذلك وأعتقد غالبًا
أنني منجذبة لأفترض أن القضايا
التي أعتقد أنها قضايا مهمة وأعتقد
أنه ينبغي علينا جميعًا  كن على دراية بأم لأنك
تعلم أنها إما تؤثر علينا
بشكل مباشر أو أنها مشكلة أنه إذا
انتبه المزيد من الأشخاص ، فقد
تعلم أن هذه المشكلة قد يتم إصلاحها بشكل
أسرع كثيرًا ، لذا فهم غالبًا
ما يجذبونني  فيلمك الأخير
في الغبار
لماذا اختارت أزمة المياه
لتكون موضوع هذا الفيلم وأيضًا لماذا
برافين رحمن بطلة القصة ،
لذا بدأ هذا الأمر في الغبار بشكل جدي
عندما علمنا بقصة بافين
رامان وأختها كيلو
وأعتقد أن إسماعيل وأنا أذهلني حقًا
بشجاعة هاتين المرأتين اللتين
تناضلتا من أجل حقوق المواطنين الأكثر ضعفًا في كراتشي على
الرغم من
التهديدات الهائلة التي يتعرضون
لها ، وأعتقد بصفتي مخرجًا
أنني كنت محظوظًا بما يكفي لقضاء الكثير من
حياتي
يروون قصصًا عن الأشخاص الذين
يخاطرون بحياتهم من
أجل قضية أكبر من أنفسهم
وأعتقد أن قصتهم تلخص حقًا
أنها كانت أيضًا قصة
تحدثت عن أزمة المياه العالمية
لم أسمع أبدًا أن العالم كان
يواجه حقًا المياه  الأزمة
وقد صدمت عندما علمت أنه في
غضون بضعة عقود فقط ، ستعرف أن خمسة مليارات شخص
سيعانون من إجهاد مائي مرتفع أو مرتفع للغاية ،
وهذا مورد نعتمد عليه جميعًا كل يوم
من أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة ، وجدت أن هذا أمر
صادم حقًا ، وأخيرًا ، فإن سبب
إعجابي بهذه القصة هو أنني أفترض على
المستوى الشخصي حقًا أنه كان
لدي أخ مات صغيرًا جدًا ، لقد جربت
ما يشبه فقدان شقيق عقيلة
فقد رصيفه  في وقت مبكر جدًا بالنسبة
للجمهور الذي
سيشاهد الفيلم ولأولئك الذين شاهدوا الفيلم ،
ما هي الرسالة المباشرة
التي تريد أن يحصلوا عليها هل هي رسالة
حول أزمة المياه أم أنها
رسالة حول
[الموسيقى
] العصابات  والجرائم المنظمة في
باكستان وفي البلدان النامية
بشكل عام ، ما الذي تحاول
قوله هنا ، أعني أن هناك
شيئان أحبهما للناس
وأتمنى أن يأخذ الناس من هذه القصة
ما يجب
أن يفهمه المرء تمامًا حول الأزمة التي
تواجه  يُظهر العالم من حيث الماء
والكاراتشي من بعض النواحي مثالًا أكثر
حدة ويظهر مثالًا على
المكان الذي يبدأ فيه الماء في الندرة
، فهو ليس مجرد صنابير جافة ، بل
تعرف تآكلًا  الحوكمة
ونسخة من سيادة القانون وأعتقد أنها
تعزز الإجرام وهذا هو نوع
الأشياء التي تنتهي بالحدوث ، لذا
نأمل بالتأكيد
أن يدرك الناس أنهم سيفكرون في
البصمة المائية الخاصة بهم ، فنحن جميعًا ندرك
ما  البصمة الكربونية ولكن لدينا جميعًا
بصمة مائية جيدًا ، سؤالي الأخير
بالنسبة لك هو ما التالي بالنسبة لك
ما هو في خط الأنابيب
أم تعلم أن هذا هو السؤال
الذي يصعب الإجابة عليه حقًا
لأننا نعمل على العديد من الأشياء المختلفة وفي
الغالب
إذا  لم نصدرهم ، لا يمكننا
حتى التحدث عنهم
بشكل عام ،
هل هناك فيلم جديد قادم فيلم روائي
آخر ، حسنًا ، يمكنني التحدث عن أحدهم ، نعم ،
هناك فيلم
يوجد فيه فيلم سيصدر في وقت
مبكر  عام
يطلق عليه من نفس
الشيطان وهو فيلم عن الاستعادة
والتنوع البيولوجي وأزمة المناخ ،
ما
اختياره في المنفضة من أنفاس الشيطان ،
إنها أسماء مدهشة حسناً
أورلاندو شكرًا لك  نعم جزيلاً على هذه
المقابلة ونتمنى لك المزيد من الأفلام
والمزيد من جوائز الأوسكار
لتكون أه على الطاولة أيضًا
شكرًا جزيلاً لك شكرًا جزيلاً لك